[Music]
hey in this video I'm gonna give you
young guys out there style tips to look
better now these are five style tip that
I wish I knew when I was younger so
let's not waste any more time let's get
right into the video made mistakes but
mistakes make you strong hey if you're
new here to my channel I'm Daniel and
welcome to D LM model lifestyle
subscribe and also click that
notification belt so you won't miss any
of the next videos now when I first
started my modeling career I always
wanted to look good right but my fashion
sense was zero but over the years I
learned what really matters when it
comes to style and it's really good if
he can learn this at a young age and not
struggle with it like I did over the
years and there was no one to really
help me with it
but as I said it's good for you to learn
this at a young age because it's gonna
save you time money and well let me just
start with the first step and you'll get
it you have to ignore fashion trends why
well here's the thing fashion trends
change too fast and you end up wasting
your money rather invest in your future
and invest in quality clothing that will
never go out of style also whenever
there's a new fashion trend everybody
ends up looking the same so you're not
really standing out at all you know you
see what most models wear on the runway
but that doesn't mean we like it I mean
there's some pretty weird stuff that we
will never wear so the fashion industry
creates new clothes every now and then
you fall for the medias advertising
tricks and you just spend your money and
before you know it there's new clothes
and there's new trends and you're out of
style so this cycle just keeps on
repeating itself over and
again so take more fashion trends you
gotta have self-confidence now you've
probably heard this before on a lot of
videos but what does it mean when it
comes to style well it's not just about
what you wear but it is about how you
wearing your clothes and your whole
image looks a lot better if you wear it
with a lot of self-confidence and it's
not about getting girls it's about
what's deep in your soul your driving
force knowing who you are and what you
stand for self confidence is not oh they
will like me it's more like I'll be fine
if they don't it's like good care of
your clothes yes I know it's a something
that your mom would say right but look
at me more like an older brother most
young guys don't have a lot of money to
spend on new clothes all the time so we
buy something take good care of it and
be proud of it and learn how to wash
your clothes the right way with the
right detergent and use a softener and
don't let it hang in the Sun for hours
after you washed it and then also guys
learn how to iron your shirts properly
so that it doesn't leave any stains buy
quality clothing and not quantity did
you know that second to oil the clothing
and textile industry is the largest
polluter in the world 20% of global
wastewater is produced and by the
fashion industry people are just buying
and throwing away clothes like it's
nothing and I don't even realize that
they are destroying the earth you're not
part of the solution you're part of the
problem in America alone 26 billion
pounds of textiles and clothes end up in
landfills but it doesn't have to so
focus on buying quality instead of
quantity it will last you a lot longer
you end up saving money and you look
better with quality clothes
where clothes that fit your body
oversized baggy clothes that never look
good on anyone I mean it's okay when you
wear it at home when you want to relax
but when you go to events wear clothing
that fits you well when you look at
buying clothes the fit is very very
important so don't buy it if it doesn't
fit you now remember it's not about the
brand it's about style and style is
saying who you are without even speaking
now if you want to see some more style
videos check out one of these and if you
like this video keep it a thumbs up
subscribe and we will talk soon Cheers
[Music]